hey everyone the Han Solo movies solo a
Star Wars story now has an official
synopsis released by Disney yet still no
trailer but that doesn't matter because
we here at new rock stars don't need
trailers to predict what's gonna happen
in movies do we know rhetorical no we
got it and we're gonna break down
everything we know at this point about
the Han Solo movie which isn't too much
but you know speculation goes a long way
we're also gonna get into why doesn't it
maybe being so hush-hush about this
movie yeah we'll get there but first
welcome to the new rock stars news our
weekly deep dive and all the biggest
stories this week including the latest
about Jake Gyllenhaal possibly taking
over as Batman and that controversial
fan edit of Star Wars the last Jedi and
more great news well I'm Erik Bosse and
joining me in this wretched hive of scum
and villainy all right is ready huh I
don't like you doesn't like you either
all right P I'm Maude Garrett hey guys
come on back Sam
I've taken a lot of dayquil today so I
believe in you high five I'm sick you
can do this for our top story the Han
Solo movie got an official synopsis
revealed by Disney this week here's what
it says board the Millennium Falcon and
journey to a galaxy far far away so Star
Wars story and all new adventure with
the most beloved scoundrel the galaxy oh
through a series of daring escapades
deep within I can't take this seriously
turgid dangerous criminal underworld
han Solo meets his mighty future
co-pilot to barkos that's cool and
encounters the notorious gambler Lando
Calrissian sign me up
in a journey that will set the course of
one of the Star Wars saga is most
unlikely heroes through that four hours
later some of that is great right yeah
maybe the directors might be swept out
at some point here yes not a lot of
shockers there yet you know Disney does
seem to be playing this one close to the
chest for some reason as we pointed out
last week Disney has released teasers
for its Star Wars movies at least eight
months ahead of the release date and
here we are four months well four months
in one week ahead of solos current
release date of May 25th still nada
I don't know that release date will hold
usually do they like plant the seed and
then like obsessed let it stop let it
begin yeah start making long obsessive
videos about it to do our marketing for
us not the worst idea that's not that if
you gave it to like nerd channels like
this to really like start building the
hype train do it's free it's nothing of
like a simple task for kindergarten also
the instructions and a chewy and you
meet lander instructions for an Origin
movie they just added the characters for
the film in there you could also put
like also a scoundrel named Iron Man
meeting roadie and Pepper Potts or it's
like scoundrel Peter Parker meeting it
was like yeah just manatees in a tank
putting these things will be in a movie
together and you'll pay great money to
see I mean that's obviously the clue
here right like we they don't even need
to release the trailer really I mean I'm
gonna pay to see any Star Wars movie
well get actually here's what we do know
about that what we can talk about isn't
like do not appreciate introduce all
these people to you the cast includes
Alden Ehrenreich as a young Han Solo and
Donald Glover as young Lando Calrissian
Woody Harrelson walls to be playing a
new character named Beckett criminal and
Hans mentor and Emilia Clarke would play
Keira another
newcomer we don't know too much about
Harrelson being a mental I'm pretty sure
I saw this in full movies when it should
have only been to four movies in the
same year it's a very impressive Hunger
Games I was looking for that answer $200
on the obvious geek facts BAM yep a fun
fact about the name Keira and when they
were developing force awakens kir was
actually going to be raised name before
they changed it she was listed and
concept art under the name Keira so I
guess they're like like the name we'll
figure out of Star Wars movie to play to
them at some point
now it's Kira right Lee of course Chewie
yeah he'll be coming back Tanny Newton
will and and Paul Bettany will also
appear plain unknown Paul Bettany is
actually playing a CGI character like
numerous pitch in Parks and Rec for the
Star Wars trilogy mixing with tomorrow
just do it more and more wolverine could
never come over but it's served for some
of the possible reasons why this might
be sort of late the trailer might be
last summer previous directors Phil Lord
and Chris Miller were replaced with Ron
Howard after rumors of the movie needed
to be reshot and Ehrenreich stake on Han
Solo was to improvi and over the top one
source comparing him to Ace Ventura I
love that hi I know I'm not the PERT
that it's not marketed to me but I love
everything you just said honestly I feel
like Disney went threw money at them
because they've gone everything that
you've done has been gold lately Lego
movies the 21 22 Jump Street like it's
really really funny but I rely think
that they've realized that by applying
that extreme comedy which is very improv
heavy too a very protective and safe
franchise for the majority even though
the last Shadow was not really that safe
they doing some risks yeah yeah I feel
like they've gone up too far oh no and
you can't pull back up cool we're gonna
get dad running or they did or Larry
Kasdan who wrote the original scripts in
script reports Wiccans it was probably
like this is my character this is my
baby han Solo
this is my voice you can't just in
prov through his voice you gotta have
good one-liners and your improvised
one-liners while you know a2c improv
connection thinking is great and natural
and grounded isn't something that could
be written in by a brilliant
screenwriter like me so give me dr.
reigns they're improving a character
that has existed for decades so there is
not as much flexibility with what you
can get away with and what actually fits
in within the characters guidelines yeah
yeah true but also since that character
is gonna run for so long you should but
you actually could go both ways like if
a character is totally unknown you can
that's free rein to do whatever you want
cuz you get to establish what they're
like but also after a certain amount of
time you're like like Riverdale for
example like Archie there's nothing to
do with what happened to that show
whatsoever by the orange hair and that's
it that's it
and like but you get to do whatever you
want because the characters been around
for so long so that there's give and
take I get go on that notion you're
saying that it's so it's a rewarding to
genre switch at the moment
Logan genre flip it turned into a
westerner completely changed the dynamic
and the tone of what you usually catch
with an x-men movie in this case Star
Wars family re-entered you know the go
get him hero that kind of swashbuckling
adventure but for the the space why not
make it a comedy yeah I think the
difference is at least with Logan as
Hugh Jackman was a producer on it that
movie didn't get made without Hugh
Jackman whereas maybe some people are
like well Harrison ports not here we're
bringing in this new fairly unknown
actor to take control the character I
don't know how comfortable I am
completely changing the tone of it I
don't know I like Lord and Miller I was
really bummed to see them leave don't
forget Ron Howard directed willow and
George Lucas wrote that mm-hmm is that
good willow yeah willows one of the best
movies of all time one of the Bears not
Princess Bride but one of the best you
give me in the comments about that
because I've never seen willow I'm sorry
Louis I still don't know if she's she
loves it slow on game of what good will
are played by Warrick Davis you're
kidding me little Peck oh my god does is
she calling me a little bit
I guess we have some summer reading we
will watch the only other new thing we
know about the Huntsville movie is that
John Williams of course will be
composing a new theme I realize I don't
know Han Solo has his own music he has a
han and Leia theme he has like the
general what if it takes off something
like Indiana Jones yeah what if it's in
that kind of capacity where there is a
new like Soler Thebes I'm so about that
and I know John Williams can do it this
is so great I mean everything he's
composed for the new trilogy has been
like money I love all this new stuff
even better - I mean just my personal
preference I love the kylo Ren and Rey
theme they're separate themes as much as
the originals but actually let's roll
some golden dice here to make some
educated guesses on where the star was
team has planned for the new Han Solo
movie what what yes guys want to see on
this I just wanna know what that
reference is now I just feel really get
the girl nice I now know what that is
yeah Oh Star Wars fans you can suck it
because I now know what that reference
is and what do I think thank you like
what right you were talking about doing
a okay with being a comedy are there any
other genres or any other past movies
that you would like to see Han Solo go
in that direction or err think about it
there's a there's some there's an alien
on the Millennium Falcon wait a minute
you guys we're locked down we're
floating at the force awakens next yeah
that wasn't that was not a horror movie
but they had a monster trapped in the
Millennium that was good just remember
that tentacles moving down a hallway the
one horror
ESCO spooky yeah are you out the trash
compactor monster kind of moment work
your horn I'm just like I'm pitching
this but I really think about it you
gotta like a bunch of young actors
they're all like you know it's like camp
counselor like the you know the last day
of camp they're all hanging out together
on the Millennium Falcon space and uh-oh
something's snuck aboard and it's moving
through the air vents oh no and then
they all got a team together to take it
down and something about the force or
something there's one Jon right let's do
a good one now
I would like I mean a Western is also
not a bad idea why can't we have the
solo movie be a little bit like Ferris
Bueller's Day Off where it takes place
over like the one day and all this
adventure happens and there's near
misses and there's a lot of suspense
raised in that and obviously like the
first pillow the name there's like a
reputation and a hype involved I kind of
like that idea and then you've got you
know the same thing with Kasdan being
technically an 80 script writer that
kind of lends itself to Ferris Bueller's
as well hmm
and then maybe not have the musical
number but I was about to say there's no
way you could do this movie without a
musical yeah a musical number and a foot
chase through several people's houses
and then these stops to talk to some
girls and then break the fourth wall I
don't even care if someone says I got a
bad feeling about this and he's like
every cast member looks no push you over
the pain of the way basically you're
about to get the tracking shot through
the through the neighbors yards but it's
ship-to-ship
they do and they plate and then they
play Ferris Bueller exactly and no he's
gonna do shout in a big space parade
he's gonna do it on a jar jar's plan of
course in the underwater whatever there
you go thank you so much needed the
assist there technically a different
City
there you go still owe me thank it plays
the principal you have Emilia Clarke can
be like the sister being like now he's
up to something or Greg yeah Lando can
be the the one with the Corvette yeah
hold on Woody Harrelson's gonna be
Rooney yeah
worse move I bet Ventura you know Chuy's
like the blanking on the female leads
character in that movie but like yeah
there you go mm-hmm unless unless Chuy's
the older sister who's like we got to
figure out where that who's gonna play
Charlie Sheen's burn out care he's a
gambling addicts really yeah sorry
that kind of goes hand-in-hand with a
drug addiction but if you wanted to you
could go like western and you could go
with a bounty hunter
you could definitely go with a bounty
hunter storyline and you're gonna have a
version of Boba Fett no in a very cool
way that we've never seen the movies
before it again like Captain phasma was
supposed to be like Boba Fett standin
and still didn't really get anywhere
near the height so we wanted dude press
for that too of the world and depress
twice for two movies global you know
four minute interview of mine than she
did in the movie like she really doesn't
do prep for that role she just but no
like if you did a Western where it's
like you get a showdown on like you do a
western planet not a desert planet and
there's a there's a difference you have
a lot of fun there we're taking outpost
or something I love that idea only
because this is not the first time that
Baba and Han Solo have met and yet it's
Bopper that cashes in on the bounty that
the Hutt's put out the one who put out
knowing that they have inter intertwine
I think they kind of did this a little
bit in rebels with Sabine's character
she kind of used to be used to take
bounties and then there was like a
fellow bounty hunter and they ended up
working together even though they were
kind of like arch-nemesis if that was
the case because they're both smugglers
but if I could easily take a bounty that
smuggles
and then it's like boom I need you know
cut to Empire Strikes Back I need
someone to catch a han Solo he'd be like
now do you get here's where I can get
really really cool do they team up and
they actually go after they just decide
to actually it becomes a heist and they
steal from the huts or whoever has like
the the bounty on them so they steal
their units of credits what everyone
when a heist movie though I think they
pitched it as that but then I didn't
really have to go to retrieve there's a
horrible heist movie because at the end
it was just at war like they really did
right they didn't nail it but like the
planned using the same infiltration
plotline that's used in pretty much
every Star Wars movie oh look some spera
imperial under well just put it on and
yeah blend right in and no one will look
at my face I realize I do have to
request something from the solo movie
that I've been requesting from a Star
Wars movie
I think for since before the force
awakens can we get a botton in the solo
well many of them died to get assistance
after this yeah kind of like Bossin
dynasty like a dog humanoid character so
it's like a person but like with a dog
like face furry why does that matter
Sam betcha know if furry is it's a
preference that you have I think the
same is admitting to us some details
about himself that I'm just saying it's
a furry and you do what you will with it
information I'm not I'm definitely
there's a couple things that I want to
see from this I want to see cuz
everyone's talking about how seeing Han
win the Falcon from Lando I think
because it's gonna be so built up I'd
love to see them open with that scene
get out of the way like kind of the way
Titanic opens with Jack winning the
tickets to on the board I want to see
like them open with with the game where
they win it I just gotta get out of the
way I may be like I'd love to see a
Terrence universe of that like a
hatefully or that scene in Inglourious
Basterds where they're just like in a
bar and it's like really tense but also
kind of funny in a way saga' I would
love to see like a slow burn character
based intense scene and then everything
after that just to be a long foot chase
through people's backyards you know like
yeah the trailing of the cigar smoke on
all years well well
what have we looking at who's the
backhand yeah cuz it's technically it's
kind of like a cod game in a way tiles
you play a Knut ståle republic a lot
yeah so back so back yeah I mean you
just hear in the back of the sea in the
back of the room they turn it's a Hut
back there oh I thought you're me is
that flying purple blue guy from what I
from the one oh yeah Wow totally
different you know all right well uh let
us know um what you guys are hoping to
see from this Han Solo movie what
theories do you have on why it's being
delayed do you think the release state
will be moved and are you excited
forgetting there's a few movies there's
so many movies coming out this year like
there's another expert do you know how
many x-men movie actually is only two
now there's only two that we're gonna be
a new mutant
well let's move on our trivia question
and things are going to be staying Han
Solo related here oh that's actually
funny that you mentioned Sabac or
Sibbach because our question is what is
the name of the dice game that according
to legend Han Solo played against Lando
Calrissian to win the Millennium Falcon
it's a specific type of sabacc or soo
bahk and they're looking for the
specific name of the type of the variant
that Han Solo played to win so this is
again those are what those dice
signified in the last Jedi in case you
were wondering
oops wrote that down before those dots
yeah it's a it's a dice type of game I
would imagine it's kind of like grab
some dice gambling game and I'm gonna
put
well and yeah cuz I don't leave too much
dead air here okay so as always baby
wrong answers now later in the show
reveal the answer to this trivia
question the closest answer has decided
by our judges will do our sign-off
good-byes at the end of the video and do
it whatever and um baby boy came out to
read in other news wrap-up headlines now
we're actually going to talk more about
Star Wars late in this episode
specifically the last shot I thin edit
that people have been talking a lot
about but for now let us move on because
this is new rock stars news we cover all
the stuff that you really need to know
about from this week including guys the
news that came out this week that Jake
Gyllenhaal could be taking over the role
of Batman from Ben Affleck in the
upcoming Batman film directed by Matt
Reeves a source close to the film was
quoted as saying this that even though
Affleck has has a contract currently the
studio is annoyed with him and that if
he leaves that Gyllenhaal's in guys now
we've talked to before HUD other actors
who could take over the role of Batman
by Jake Gyllenhaal is a very interesting
choice would you say attractive no but
it is true he is very putting words in
my mouth
we're in the oh my gosh you know he's
not cleaning that rich sure sure all
that sitting water but there was talk
also that Jon Hamm could possibly that
was one of the names that's been
floating around
Virgil yeah he's got some fire there but
you know it's almost like the studio
would be aiming to go back to the days
of Michael Keaton you know more the
unhinged goofball plus possibly Bruce
Wayne in the series brooding once played
by Affleck and Christian Bale yes think
what passed Gyllenhaal roles do you
could you see influencing its take on
that I actually don't talk about his
acting career because he's been in the
biz for a long time
Bubble Boy yeah sure that's a great
start but the fact that he went into
prince of persia means that we're not
afraid not afraid to dip his toes into
the geek slash video game maybe comic
book genre I think for the last sort of
10 years of his career he's been taking
roles that are supposed to be Oscar bait
you know he does such a good job in he's
actually a fantastic actor and for some
reason the Academy Board just never even
considers him for these particular roles
I think even last year those a movie is
it strong we're strong this year it was
like right the the right Boston bomber
victim yeah that's this year that was
here but even then it's not in any
conversations for Golden Globes or I've
heard amazing because he's so good in
that movie and a crawler
like the big one the big one for him yet
completely overlooked now he needs to be
the other Nightcrawler Batman but I
think in his career now is a great time
to do it and I feel like he's still got
enough of his youth that if he wants to
sign on to a four movie deal he could
actually see it out which is something
that I don't think Jon Hamm could
actually do yeah
I'm sorry oh hey Jake Jon Hall Hugh
Jackman they didn't movie together
it was prisoners yeah and yeah who
directed that was that Matt Reeves as
well Jenny Villeneuve all right I was
thinking like oh they've already worked
together so they'll be very cool to see
them come back together my bad
I think though Matt Reeves has just such
this interesting way of working with his
actors like yeah if you haven't seen the
last to plan of the apes movies they're
amazing and he's done films before that
but those are what I know him from it
he's just so impressive and I I would
like to see what he could do with Jake
Gyllenhaal because he like Ben Affleck
is a good actor no one's questioning
that but Jake just gets into the role
and I want to see him get into a role
like that yeah I think what I really
like about him video mask on I mean I
don't know where to begin with
but no he's nice to me he brings two
things to this part if he'd potentially
if he plays this role he's a super
physical actor like the way he tackled
that role with nightcrawlers just so in
Irving like this facial expressions and
his whole physicality but like the he's
also the type of he's played a lot of
characters were like investigators you
know with like zodiac and prisoners yeah
it's like trying to get to the truth and
it sounds like Matt raves from what I've
heard from rumors that he wants to do
that kind of the greatest detective in
the world angle of Batman he's trying to
like solve some kind of mystery which we
haven't really seen a lot in Batman he's
usually just a guy who like vigilante
justice cleans up clean ass but now like
I'd love to see the version of Batman
he's trying to get to the bottom of
something and I like Gyllenhaal's the
kind of guy who would love to see go on
that journey I also think the number one
question you should ask with anyone who
could potentially pay Batman is can they
also play a good Bruce Wayne yeah
and I think that he could do a really
good way Keaton did like he could play
kind of that unhinged eccentric
billionaire I mean I don't need him to
be I don't need Bruce Wayne to be
eccentric it's fun like I do like what
Michael Keaton did for that but I do
like what Ben Affleck brought to Bruce
Wayne cause he like he had the look of
Bruce Wayne really really down well so I
would be the most is the best option
I've heard so far obviously I have
something John Hamill will nail in mmm
Mad Men I also want to point at the fact
that he's played a soldier in a lot of
movies before he hadn't seen jarhead
it's absolutely amazing but the
physicality required to get in the suit
and to not actually have the suit give
you six-pack mm-hm actually I would like
to see him play around with the Justice
League more than I want to see Ben
Affleck's Batman player I think I think
he would he play like the way he plays
off of other actors we have the gaga
Wonder Woman can we have that story and
the Batman Mike the kind of like love
they already kind of have little hints
of it with Ben Affleck like I could I'd
like to see I like this I don't mind a
flex take on it I just I think it should
all seems like more of a team player I
don't know yeah hopefully
you hope yeah
well we'll hear more about this film
when it eventually gets released in 2028
but let us know your thoughts on on
Gyllenhaal's potential casting I did
like also just to add that someone in a
quote said well the Matt Reeves movie
might be in continuity or it might not
be oh right own story and in between the
lines it was suck it alright just right
just watch the movie
people write it eventually I'm waiting
for my final draft software to read all
right
okay everyone recently someone rieta
today our Wars the last Jedi into a 46
minutes recut that's causing a bit of
controversy this anonymous editor in
troll removed massive sections of the
film including cutting out a lot of the
female characters calling it his de
femme Anais fan edit he also removed a
and reordered a ton of sequences it
justice recut totally incomprehensible
it's hard to see how this person even
considered himself a fan at all director
Rian Johnson and several of the film's
cast members simply responded by
tweeting endless laughter and laugh
emojis which is probably the best way to
respond to this guy's because clearly
this editor is just a troll trying to
rile people up thank you for saying that
because that needs to be put out there
this dude's just doing it so that we
talk about him right he's just once a
rise out of people I don't do you
believe that he actually like no yeah
okay I think I think on some level he
has to love Star Wars in order to spend
the time to read it very protective it
sounds like it's this is my Stahl wasn't
even do my Star Wars how I would have
done it so I'm gonna do it now yeah I'm
gonna do it and rather than just show it
my friends I'm going to release it out
there just to see how people react and
what headlines they'll get um think
peace blog it would have taken a lot of
time and effort so spend all that time
and just show his friends what a waste
well having watched it unfortunately I
can I did I sped through parts of it but
I can honestly tell you that was just a
huge waste of 46 minutes guys it just
made the last Jedi worry whatever you
didn't like about the last Jedi it just
made it worse and it ruined things he
did like about it but I thought I'd jump
on this grenade for everyone and explain
what the big changes were some of which
are just laughably weird and I'm gonna
go they're just my top 5 most ridiculous
ones okay in the scene where kylo and
Leia
via the forest during the battle and
Kyla decides to hold off and this recut
Kiley just immediately blasts the bridge
it killed his mom doesn't me think about
and this version this actually kills
Leia there's a long shot of her frozen
face I guess it's a tribute to Carrie
Fisher but she never comes back into the
movie so Carrie Fisher is not a woman
yeah she's just a an object that you
want to just stare at I don't know it's
so really good okay also strangely rays
cave mirror scene was left in in its
entirety but her forced timing with kylo
was cut along with Luke and kylos
conflicting accounts of what went down
between them and the whole Yoda scene
okay so Yoda is actually a woman right
no one's been able to say otherwise
wasn't there a female Yoda at all pretty
cool yeah on the other Jedi Council yes
there was I know that I I just don't get
why you would keep some of this weird
mythology stuff but then you'd be
annoyed by some of it to not get yeah
it's just all over the place in terms of
what this guy's agenda was okay all the
stuff on canta bite and Laura Dern's
character hold oh were removed don't
hate
I get where he's coming on some of that
but this Joker made it look like Poe
Dameron was the one who kamikaze the
radisson to the supremacy even though in
this cut Poe Dameron shows up later in
the Battle of Crete that is logic trying
to use how dare you it was ridiculous so
he just took shots of Poe in like the
pilot's seat and then like a wide shot
of it you know hyper hyper speeding into
the end of the supremacy and then like
later poacher shows up no questions
doesn't make sense now when kylo Geist
yeah he's but he's got a new Jedi pal
which made him materialize in the flesh
and really be that yeah well maybe he
just chucked the Luke we don't know when
kylo skewers Snoke this is my favorite
when he kills snook with a lightsaber
this guy did some really goofy effect to
make Snoke fade away like cross-dissolve
with really bad repurposed audio Snoke
sane and laughing haha you fool what
just happened and then in the white shop
then fighting you see like Snoke severed
corpse there but I guess he liked Obi
and away from it I don't really know
what he was going to another right and
then finally Luke's appearance on crate
at the end isn't forced projection in
this re-edit it's actually Luke there's
no Larry in the incas remember she's
dead Luke just shows up winking at
Threepio and then walks out to face the
first order the walkers fire on him and
then immediately dies there's no battle
with Kyle oh that's movie pretty much
ends yeah so that's why I think this is
kind of a troll and guys there are a lot
of ways to talk about I kind of don't
want to give this guy the pleasure of
being offended politically which is
probably what he wants on some level but
I do think this brings up an interesting
conversation about fan edits in general
this isn't the first time someone has
rieta dat Star Wars movies trying to
like fix perceived shortcomings in 2012
Topher Grace the actor edited the
prequels into one 85 minute movie that
he showed the friends at a private
screening and they also do is pretty
good it begins with the Darth Maul duel
from Phantom Menace and the mostly
statistics to Anakin's journey to become
vader after that leaving out the Trade
Federation clone war political stuff I
have to agree with his editor it's so
well done we never needed a
nine-year-old anni we didn't write that
whole exposition it could have been done
in a shot and then boom straight to the
good juicy stuff yeah I mean as a screen
art of myself I kind of just want to let
the creator's work stand on its own like
whether I like it or not I like who
knows how her attitudes will change over
the years right like I know I've enjoyed
Revenge of the Sith more and more over
the years after initially like kind of
you know have you really watched it
you've just watched a couple times and
I'm like you know what that there's
parts of this that are way better than
parts of Return of the Jedi I know yes
great Ewan McGregor's great now
apartments great the writing's a little
goofy but the directing of the actors is
a little goofy but anyway I want to know
what you guys think like is that ever
justified to create a fan edit of Star
Wars movies or any movie for that matter
I mean when it comes to justified
it's just fans in most cases celebrating
something yeah in other cases they think
they can fix it this what we've been
talking about for the majority of this
conversation is clearly done just to be
troll and if you want to do that that's
fine because sometimes that's the
funniest like I saw a fan edit of
Harry Potter where it's on it's on the
it's on the train in the first movie and
his glasses are broken and her mind he's
gonna be like oh I know it's but I can
fix that Ivana Cadabra and credits roll
I think there's there's is a it just
depends yep a parody or yeah there's a
rillette it of a scene in the Deathly
Hallows final movie where like Voldemort
has that weird hug of mouth no there's I
think it's there's a time to place and I
think the most exciting part is when
there's like a celebration of it there's
plenty of thin edits of trailers out
there where they're like oh I made
crisis a DC versus Marvel and I always
watch them I'm like you know what
overall like you guys took the time to
sit there and cut out all these
characters in these scenes and put them
together for the most part it works and
I appreciate what you did like it yeah
for the most part it's for the most part
it's harmless I mean I find it's under
the same umbrella as people that want to
sew costumes to replicate a character
those who want to draw fan art you know
it's there it's kind of making content
from an already established piece of
content really but again like all things
on the Internet just because you have
freedom of speech doesn't mean it's
freedom to be an [ __ ] yeah good on
him that's how he's decided to use his
time yeah and you know I suppose
sometimes a great discussion and usually
in this case just a goddamn eye roll
yeah right like I think if your attitude
going in to do a fan edit is like like
Sam said to celebrate it or yeah to make
a new piece of content that is just
enjoying it great if you're going in to
like fix things it's like there's so
many other things in the world that you
can fix or you can create new content
that that speaks you're horribly cynical
and backwards point of view but anyway
that's just me instead of fan editing
maybe just do a fan film Star Wars 360
thang and it's a celebration of Star
and a completely different character
that we've never seen before we write an
original piece in this devil's universe
there you go that sounds great
3:16 you can do something that has like
almost an academic analytical take on it
right like I saw someone put on Vimeo a
recut of the original alien and
Prometheus and Prometheus kind of had
you know some people who weren't crazy
about it but they called it derelict and
they took pieces of both films they put
it all in black and white it looked
gorgeous and they they used it to tell
these parallel timelines of like
Ripley's character and then the leaf
character whose name I don't remember in
Prometheus they they ended up like
making something new out of both films
and showed how both of these characters
were in similar situations and it didn't
feel like it was being cynical toward
Prometheus it just showed like hey there
are things about this movie that are
still really good because notice how you
loved them when they're an alien and
what if there was just there's these
historical reverberations in the way
that the arrogance of these scientists
and assuming that they can they're in
control of nature
I loved it they had to take it down
because Warner Brothers liked but in
that case I think there are examples if
you really put in the time and you have
an attitude of let's try to like find
what really worked about these and make
something new out of it it's gonna be
great have you seen the one where if you
do want a good fam fam was universe and
to really appreciate the genius level of
vision that George Lucas did have
someone has decided to edit parts of the
original trilogy alongside the prequels
it was direct sort of parallel in some
particular moments or like Reverse but
in a mirror what you know each other
yeah and it made you appreciate this the
prequels a lot more more also just to do
a little plug if I may my my co-host DJ
for only stupid answers he did a pitch
for the prequels in this really cool way
where was like Seven Samurai and obi-wan
and qui-gon or like like higher Jedi
they can come out and like help protect
you and I like had boat
Jango Fett my kennel it was of his idea
for the the prequels made me excited and
wanted me to go made me want to go watch
but I'm like I'm not gonna see what he
just told me but as a celebration of fan
edits and fan like changes he did a good
job so all these two bands are gonna go
listen to it so it was a fun episode
well let us know your thoughts about
this fan edit in the comments and tweet
us directly and as a reminder just
follow and subscribe to new rock stars
for more in depth breakdowns and
analysis star wars thanks everybody
ok let us move on to our need to know
answer them quickly without hesitation
as possible ready guys yet here we go
Sam your choice to keep forever and not
recast Evans as Captain America or
Robert Downey jr. as start yeah that's
him and not you could recast at that MIT
Lily Mason wants to know who is the
fictional character you'd go to talk to
about your problems in life Oh quick
anyone anyone late like mine was stolen
from x-men
shoulder to cry on and for me at 52 what
does the a stand for and your Twitter
name Twitter name a TA vas it's so ei a
is my middle initial it says for Axl Axl
is my middle name a XE I was I was going
for Aaron Aaron Phillip always calls me
Aaron just to belittle me he said
actually actually this actually adds
Harrison it's not an Axl
he's in here so it's pretty good oh yes
better that's a conversation for another
time well um you know tweet us your
ability
lightning round tweet and respond for
your questions so hopefully we can get
him on the air thank you to all of you
who sends questions but next up let's
move on take a look at what we got in
the pipeline for videos coming out on
this channel next week okay guys we're
still on the lookout for a han Solo
trailer as soon as it comes you know
you're gonna get a breakdown get a
breakdown you know talk about it but
Sam's got another video coming I do and
I hope you guys are enjoying the MCU
rewatch breakdowns I did I did the first
Iron Man movie is so much fun there's a
lot of really cool Easter eggs in that
for like the x-men that they hidden
there it's it's really subtle but I
think Kevin thought you did on purpose
but I'm going later this weekend be
releasing the Hulk breakdown the Edward
Norton Hulk and there was a lot of
really fun behind-the-scenes stuff in
the next I'm doing is Iron Man 2 I'm
gonna be working my way up until I catch
up to the ones you guys have already
done so I hope you enjoy make sure you
check it out share with your friends
yeah
we're also looking at doing a breakdown
of the movie Jumanji that holidays
number one movie you guys have been
tweeting us about it and yeah it's it's
a great film we're gonna dig into some
of the stuff that maybe you miss some of
the cool things that make it a good
movie so keep an eye out for that oh
well you should just be the man in the
middle when you think about it one
because literally man is in the middle
of Jumanji we're starting with the man
in the middle a mirror yeah you can't
see my sweat right now guys we're also
doing a rematch of Game of Thrones and
as you guys know we've kind of put a
hold on doing the episode by episode
thing we are looking at ways to do an
episode by episode breakdowns for you in
different ways in the show but for now
we're just kind of going by cool moments
that all stand out in our memories so we
just did one on Ned Stark's death which
is not a spoiler it was like well I'm
like fine everyone knows he died it's
don't know quite first god no I have
amnesia in this ball but now we're gonna
be looking at the birth of Daenerys
dragons when will season 1 finale big
moment so we'll be digging into that and
Walking Dead is on the horizon so you
know we'll be doing stuff I'm walking
then Wow wowie does
you know Fanta walking dead is that hurt
yeah I love and now comes the time for a
15-second shout out ladies and gents for
each of us that's 15 seconds to shout
out plug ramble about anything Hey what
I'd say mod why don't you start but it
looks like mod is still thinking about
what she wants to shout out I think one
of my more favorite movies of 2017 was
call me by your name and also I the
reason why I was slightly cringing is
because I thought a really good
challenge for me would be to watch
Grey's Anatomy from the start again
that's thirteen seasons
oh man take a lifetime no no see you
would think so but I recently no sir I
recently just did all of Lauren or SVU
and that's 17 or 18 seasons all of them
done didn't and we're getting content
flag well I would like to shout out the
okay so I just came across this web
series Zack Morris is trash so I think
it's funny or Die produce but it's a guy
who goes back in pick specific episodes
does I do recaps of them but just from
the point of reference of the way Zack
Morris is emotionally manipulative and
abusive towards friends kind of sexual
harasser in some cases and then it's so
cruel to discreet its just say by the
Bell yeah I grew up watching it on when
I was sick I would watch or Saturday
mornings it's so cheesy and real fun but
now you're watching like awesome super
horrible person it's yeah it's uh it's
fun Zack Morris is trash check it out
yeah she recommendations real quick
because I forgot last week I said happy
again and I didn't mean to do that
Netflix they just got a documentary that
I got to see a fantastic fest finally
it's a freedom for people to watch it's
called haunters it's the making of
haunted houses so if you get a little
scared it's not as scary it's not a
scary documentary it's actually really
charming and it's really fun because
they not only talk about the origin of
haunted houses people who scare people
in haunted houses and how people love
doing it but also the origin of those
ones that are like you have to sign
waivers and they're safe words and stuff
and you realize just how effed up it
gets and it's
so charming it's hilarious but also
check out Black Lightning it's the new
CW DC show I wasn't worried I was a
little worried that like it's gonna be
another CW show it's the most aground
it's the most grounded adult show of
ever since the CW make it did as soon as
you became a superhero show I was like
oh yeah I forgot that it's doing this
because it's so different and it's so
original I think even if you're like on
the fence about watching another
superhero show or anything like that I
say just give it a chance with the pilot
it's amazing justice no it is a father
as a principal is a man who cares about
his community and then all of a sudden
he's got lightning powers and you're
like oh crap this may be coming for
lightning round okay and finally let us
return to our trivia question that we
asked earlier and and yeah okay so just
to remind you guys the question it was
what dice game what variant of sabacc
did Han play to win the Millennium
Falcon from Lando we're looking for the
name of the type of game he's smart and
he's a winner and has won probably more
than anyone else
I wouldn't even rhyme you're gonna say
Erik of Austin he's a boss I thought you
were I thought you had that right locked
and loaded
Erik Voss is a boss well I just have to
like he says sparkles avec spark sounds
like a good answer
okay well Samba says Chinese checkers
and maudette rhymes right well we have
the answer on another car and we pass it
over and our answer brilliance Pike that
sounds like a dream to the card I'll
have the Karelian spike who is some
acrylamide you I had the most random
word that sounds like it could have been
a Star Wars mine was the closest to a
gain so who was the who was I was the
most right to Sparkle Civic but right
into that alright
who's the loser Sam Chinese checkers
yeah me it's a game oh boy oh yes
nerds talking about fate games talking
about a real game I'm awful at that game
Chinese checkers well is our earth in it
technically if I say in a long time ago
no no well I'm gonna do our goodbyes and
and I'll just do whatever voice I feel
like doing but first we're gonna quickly
run through some of our in other news
headlines that is going to be brought
over to us now those in other news
headlines Sam is gonna have to read and
they're brought to us prepared by our
lovely enter and Jacquelyn
and Jacqueline Oh what is this she has
written her name and Twitter handle and
what is that you should handle on the
car don't worry I'll read it out that
way they know okay go ahead URLs ready
its youtube.com slash shin-chan a tour
that didn't help probably and help me
reading it shin janitor we got news okay
number one Nintendo introduced lab Oh a
new DIY cardboard kit that interacts
with the switches joy Kahn's allowing
you to build and play with cardboard
pianos and RC cars finally got friends
to play games with cardboard much
because I'm bored - my thing was that I
didn't have friends
or too old to appreciate it looks like
it's for Blue's Clues fans sorry it's
behind you footage from the venom movie
leaked showing Tom RT beaten up on the
ground is a figure in a hoodie stance
over them he was just attacked and fans
were just like oh god on venom that's my
joke alright three Tom Holland is
rumored to make a cameo in venom the
movie as Peter Parker not spider-man we
start goddamn time alright number five
fantastic bees to the crimes of bindle
Wald will be set in Paris that's awesome
oh and not okay with the French word for
muggle revealed this week as mole Nashik
which is no measu
and again that's as lazy as my jokes are
so we're gonna go with number 6 number 6
the final one and I'm glad because I got
to add this as I came in to shoot this
Warner Brothers announced that the
flashpoint moved he finally has director
a director just kiddin directors with
Jonathan Goldstein and John Francis
Daley writers of spider-man a homecoming
that's not a bunch a bunch days on a
bunch yeah okay just as a flash fan to
be genuine with you guys for a second
this does not make me excited I think
this is a bad
dear for a movie and this gave me no
hope hahahaha you laugh track haha won't
everything we buy every different media
company well thank you for watching this
week's episode no rockstars know soon to
be a an entity of the Walt Disney
Corporation guys it's um yeah the
singularity is soon approaching the
Disney arity whoa comment down below a
tweet us at new rock stars like this
video share it around and subscribe to
new rock stars for deep dives than all
the stuff you love guys see you next
week I wouldn't mind if they altered my
DNA so that my pupils look like Mickey
Mouse ears and that her eyes grow it's
four times the size we are one no we are
Mickey thank you little bit